who's got kids between six and eight
right now yeah
is that the age because I forget is that
the age where you'll just be with him at
the mall and they'll just all of a
sudden just start doing a dumb dance
like
is that that age they're at the mall and
all of a sudden you look over and
they're like
Jacob was around correct
and here's a couple things you need to
know about me guys around this time
first of all we had no money I was
raising three kids in one room I made a
thousand dollars a month I lived in Los
Angeles we were poor and so Jacob had a
Game Boy
Game Boy cost 200 that was a fifth
of what I made every month it was a big
purchase for me okay first thing you
need to know second thing you need to
know I was probably more strict on my
kids when they were younger than you
think I was I was a single parent I did
not know if I was ever going to meet
somebody I could not take the chance of
them thinking that this was just going
to be a [ __ ] playground the whole
time I wasn't going to be able to keep
control of the house what was important
for me that they knew that what I said
is what I meant I did I'm with that with
everybody to me I'm not a second chance
dude your chance was when I told you hey
I don't like that
I don't know why I need to say it a
[ __ ] second time it doesn't make any
sense to me so
just know that going into the story all
right so Jacob gets in the car one day
seven I pick him up at school
and he's back and he's playing his
Gameboy
and he's
and I look in the rearview I go hey he
goes yeah
I go you bring your Game Boy to school
he's like yeah
I go
that's against the rules dude and he
goes
how do you know the rules foreign
[Laughter]
I'm the only one in the car who can read
I know the rules you know
and I go you know you're not supposed to
bring that he goes yeah but it doesn't
matter because they didn't catch me
and I go I want to let you know that's
not the point of rules and I said and
just because that's your attitude I'm
gonna take a stand here and I'm gonna
tell you right now you bring that to
school again
I catch you bringing that to school
again
I'm throwing that away by the way
parents you ever ever promised a
punishment and as soon as you do you're
like
the worst was grounding because you're
like
it's that first time you ground your kid
you're like wait did I [ __ ] me up too
holy [ __ ]
oh you start thinking of different
punishments you're like I don't like
grounding anymore that's not good I
don't like that one
laughs
yo I grounded him for all summer and I
realized I'm grounded too this whole
summer oh no
I'm gonna throw that away
don't bring it to school
he said okay the next day he
goes to the bathroom we're going to
school and he leaves his backpack up
against the door now I will tell you
something else guys
I was a proud snooper through my kid's
[ __ ]
I never I will tell you this I never
snooped to bust them on regular teenage
kid stuff I snooped just in case they
were doing something that I thought was
dangerous
trouble that at my house but if you were
gonna do
Snoop I look in his bag
and there's the game boy and a 20 Bill
I'm like where the [ __ ] did he get that
oh I took
who raised kids with no money anybody
raise kids with no money yo man I will
tell you something right now when Jacob
was 18 and broke open his piggy bank he
was like what's with all these I videos
what does he need a 20 bill for he's
[ __ ] five you know
so I see it
and I don't want to bust him because
then he's just going to hide it better
next time
he needs to come clean
so we get in the car
and I start this every parent you've
done this before like what's going on
you're just trying to get the truth out
of them what's going on buddy anything
anything fun happen in school today no
you doing anything special at school no
what are you gonna play with your
friends I don't know
nothing right so then I try a different
tactic I go hey man just so you know I
don't know if I told you but today the
car is a punishment-free Zone
you don't get in trouble for anything
you admit about anybody
then he goes
I won't get in trouble
oh yeah that's right I go and you can
tell me anything man anything no trouble
you can tell me anything he goes
okay
and I looked in the rear mirror and he
goes
Trevor stuck his finger in the cat's
butt I was like what
[Applause]
first of all we don't have a cat so
you know that neighbor cat was like I'm
not going to that [ __ ] ing yard again
[ __ ] that yard I don't like it
yeah
so
I go he goes he's not gonna get in
trouble I'm like ah
not shaking his hand later but
[Applause]
I got anything else he's like no
okay
he goes in school
so I call my dad which I always do with
parenting questions
and I said to him I go I told him what
to deal with he goes you have two
options
you can bust him
or you just pretend like you didn't see
it
but if you do that just know he's gonna
think he'd get one overrun
can you handle that
I'm way too Petty for that [ __ ] guys
I can't have a seven-year-old walking
around my house thinking he's smarter
than me I can't [ __ ] have him
thinking that he knows how to get [ __ ]
over on me I just can't so I'm like yeah
I'm gonna have to [ __ ] bust it
so he gets in the car on the way home
guys it was like the best day he ever
had a school he gets in the car like how
was school he's like guys
[Applause]
the whole ride home he's pinned on a 10
about how great his day was and I will
tell you this is the type of [ __ ] I
am
that started to laugh
because I knew what 10 minutes from now
all I could think it was what a [ __ ]
emotional roller coaster today is gonna
be
so he gets in the car driving home super
psyched we get into the garage we take
the elevator up to the third floor we're
walking down the hallway
and
we get to the trash chute
and I say to him I go hey man he's like
yeah I go you want me to throw out the
Game Boy you want or you wanna
and he looked at me
just one last ditch he goes
what Game Boy
I said the Game Boy in your backpack now
anybody in here ever lied to their kids
before and tell them you had special
powers because you didn't want to
explain anything else
at one point in time I had told Jacob I
had X-ray vision
so I go the Game Boy in your backpack
and he goes I forgot
[Music]
I
forgot
yeah I was like whatever yeah you want
to throw it away you want me to he goes
you you
do it okay this is the one part I felt
bad about guys
because we had one of those long metal
shoots
yo you heard everything
yeah
[Music]
in the very last bang he was like oh
and look man if you're a parent you know
and if you've been you we've all been
kids you know you do not listen to a
single one of your parents life speeches
there isn't a word that comes out of
their mouth that you remember all your
thinking is when is this old [ __ ]
gonna stop talking yeah
and very rarely there's a time where you
think you can say something that your
kids will soak in
so I think this is the time I think he's
vulnerable enough he's open enough I can
tell him a couple things
so I say to him on the way down the
apartment I go I want to tell you a
couple things first of all that was not
fun for me
I want you to know as your dad my wish
is for you every day of your life to be
better than every day of mine what I
want is for you to be happy every day of
your life I just know that that's not
possible not only do I know that's not
possible I know that I am going to be
responsible for a lot of the days that
you are mad because I am going to make
decisions that I think are right for
your life actions reactions consequences
you picked your action you don't get to
pick everything else that comes after it
do you understand and he was like
and we get into the house
and I go tell me what you learned he
goes okay
[Music]
I learned that you do what you say
I said when he goes forever
I go what else because I learned that
there
consequences and actions and reactions I
don't know if that's the right order but
I
I know that's what happened
and I go what else did you learn
and this [ __ ] guy
dries his tears
takes his deep cleansing breath he's
just like
I'll go what else you learn he looked at
me and he goes
I know what I want for Christmas
[Applause]
guess who was dumpster diving an hour
later
now I want to tell you guys something
the reason I have never I I've waited a
long time to tell that story you know
I'm a I love telling stories to me the
biggest challenging stories are the ones
that you're counting on a laugh at the
end of the story to carry the whole
story right because if that laugh
doesn't work that's a [ __ ] TED Talk
so thank you all very much for letting
me uh tell that one that one is uh super
challenging for me I appreciate it very
much
hi
[Music]
did it
[Music]
titties that's how big our titties were
they made that noise through the air
[Music]